Good afternoon, everybody, and I really am appreciative that you're brave enough
to be here for a 4:00 PM session after a really long day.
So thank you all for being here. My name is Martha
Donahue. I'm a pediatric oncologist by training, and I currently
serve as the associate director for Peds Oncology and Rare Cancers in
the Oncology Center of Excellence.
It's my great pleasure to moderate this session, and I'd like to start off with a
big thanks to my friends at AACR for accepting
this as a topic for their regulatory policy and science session.
And thank you all again for being here.
I'm just going to
give a quick outline of the session that we are going to do today before
getting into the main presentations.
The focus of the session today is the use of pediatric extrapolation to
support drug development for pediatric patients with cancer.
Oops, I forgot to say, I have no disclosures, and the perspectives
shared by the FDA staff and other panelists in today's session
are their own and not necessarily those of their respective organizations
and places of employment.
As I was just starting to say, we're going to start off with some FDA
presentations. We'll first hear from Dr.
Lauren Price, who will provide an overview of pediatric extrapolation and its
use in oncology. And then after that, Dr.
Jiang Liu will describe the use of model-informed drug development, or
MIDD approaches, to support pediatric oncology drug development.
And that will be followed by presentations from Doctors Nicole
Dresner and Mansi Dalal, who will provide a more in-depth view of a
few case studies of pediatric approvals that relied heavily on
pediatric extrapolation. And after these talks, we'll have about
40 minutes or so for a panel discussion, and we'll take
some questions from you guys as well.
We're very lucky, aside from the FDA presenters, to be joined by Dr.
Vicky Binger, who's the President Emeritus of the Coalition Against Childhood
Cancer, and she'll provide us her perspectives on use of extrapolation
as a scholar and experienced advocate for children with cancer.
And we'll also hear from Dr. Adam Levy, a pediatric hematologist oncologist,
currently serving as the executive director and head of the Pediatric Cancer
Center of Excellence at Bristol Myers Squibb,
and they'll join us for the panel discussion in a bit.
We'd like to make this session as interactive as possible, so as the session
progresses, please think of your questions.
Going forward, we'll use first names to address each other, and now I'll turn it
over to Lauren.
Thank you so much.
So hi, everyone. My name is Lauren Price.
As Martha mentioned, I'm one of the FDA staff here presenting.
I'm a clinical pharmacology team lead at FDA, where my current work
focuses on drug development for solid tumors, and I also serve
as one of our pediatric clinical pharmacology leads within our solid
tumor division.
So as mentioned by Martha, I'll begin with an overview
of pediatric extrapolation and its use in oncology drug development.
So starting with the very basics, what exactly is pediatric
extrapolation?
So pediatric extrapolation is an approach to providing
evidence in support of effective and safe use of drugs in the
pediatric population when it can be assumed that the
course of the disease and the expected response to a medicinal product
would be sufficiently similar in a pediatric and reference population.
Notably, that reference population can be adults, but it can also include
different pediatric age subsets.
So for example, using data from adolescent patients to support a
pediatric extrapolation to younger children.
In general, the use of pediatric extrapolation helps to support
safe, efficient, and ethical pediatric drug development.
So as we all know, there are many challenges in the development of new
drugs for pediatric patients with cancer.
A few select challenges are shown here, including those related
to ethics, feasibility, and late and long-term effects.
Generally speaking, enrolling pediatric patients in a clinical
trial evaluating an investigational drug intended to treat that
patient's cancer would typically be considered acceptable with
appropriate safety monitoring and dosing considerations.
However, feasibility issues can result in very long
timelines for enrollment and completion of trials in pediatric
populations. In addition, those late and long-term
toxicities may impact pediatric patients potentially for up to
decades during and after their treatment, which may require long
durations of follow-up. Given these many challenges and
others for developing drugs in pediatric patients, pediatric
extrapolation represents an important tool in supporting efficient
drug development.
While the use of pediatric extrapolation in
oncology does appear to be increasing, the concept of pediatric
extrapolation is not new and in fact has been in US regulation
for more than 30 years. In 1994, the
pediatric labeling rule
described acceptability of pediatric extrapolation to
support pediatric use statements in labeling and specified that
pharmacokinetic or PK data and pediatric safety information be
submitted where needed.
Thirty years later, in 2024, the International Council for
Harmonisation, or ICH, published a final guideline on
pediatric extrapolation. This guideline provides consensus
recommendations for pediatric extrapolation, which I will cover in more
detail in the next few slides.One notable
difference from previous guidance on pediatric extrapolation is the
explicit allowance for extrapolation of safety where supported by
available data.
Within FDA oncology, we regularly see applications of pediatric
extrapolation, and a recent FDA evaluation found that more
than half of all new pediatric oncology indications approved
between 2013 and 2024 utilized pediatric
extrapolation in some way to support that approval.
As mentioned, we'll be discussing a few select examples throughout the
presentations today, but there are many more examples,
either that are already approved or are currently in development.
So now moving more into the actual process for conducting a pediatric
extrapolation approach.
This slide highlights the pediatric extrapolation framework that's
described in the ICH E11A guideline.
There are three main steps for pediatric extrapolation.
First, developing the pediatric extrapolation concept.
Second, creating the pediatric extrapolation plan.
And finally, executing that plan.
To develop the concept, developers must integrate available evidence
on disease, drug pharmacology, and response to treatment and
safety in the reference and target populations.
This includes assessments of the strength of evidence, the
uncertainties, and knowledge gaps that need to be addressed during development.
Once the concept has been developed, the objectives of the pediatric
extrapolation plan can be defined to address uncertainties and knowledge
gaps.
These can include plans to determine PK, dosing, efficacy,
safety as needed based on the knowledge gaps.
And then finally, executing the plan by conducting the needed studies to generate
data.
Importantly, these plans should be iterated based on the emerging data,
which can come from within the studies conducted as part of the pediatric
extrapolation plan, but can also include other sources, for example,
newly published literature.
Given the iterative nature of a pediatric extrapolation plan,
FDA strongly encourages sponsors to initiate the framework early in
their drug development plans, particularly when there is obvious
applicability to one or more pediatric cancers,
and to engage with FDA on these plans throughout development.
These discussions can occur as part of other regular milestone meetings,
but can also occur via a specific pediatric oncology
product development early advice meeting.
This slide summarizes a little more detail on the assessment of similarity and
approaches for pediatric extrapolation as outlined in the ICH
E11A.
The extrapolation approaches and potential study designs depend on a
continuum
of the level of evidence and confidence level in similarity of disease, drug
pharmacology, and response to treatment between a pediatric and reference
population.
A wide variety of data sources and types are evaluated to
support conclusions and identify gaps or uncertainties.
Since this is a continuum, the evaluation of similarity is not
intended to be a binary determination of whether the
disease or response in the reference in pediatric populations is exactly
the same or not, but rather to determine the degree of similarity or
dissimilarity.
This framework also helps to highlight that even in scenarios where
pediatric and adult cancers and response to treatment are expected to be
highly similar, we need high quality data to support a pediatric
development plan.
Now, looking at potential study designs, the types of data and designs of
studies proposed in a pediatric extrapolation plan can range from
exposure matching and enrollment in adult trials to randomized
trials conducted specifically in the relevant pediatric
population.
The specific study types needed will depend on the knowledge gaps and
degree of similarity between the pediatric population and the reference population.
It's not going. Okay, there we go. Sorry, it wouldn't connect.
So this slide provides just a little more detail on some specific considerations
when developing a pediatric extrapolation plan.
While not all elements will be applicable to all programs,
developers should generally consider things such as including adolescents in adult
trials where appropriate,
leveraging of modeling and simulation approaches, which will be discussed in more
detail by our next presenter.
These model-informed drug development or MIDD approaches can help us with
data leveraging to bridge knowledge gaps, inform clinical trial design
elements, and identify appropriate dosages for evaluation across
pediatric age ranges.
In addition, age-appropriate formulation development, including both the needed
characteristics of an age-appropriate formulation as well as the timeline
for development of that formulation should be considered.
Dosage selection and the use of dose ranging data and biomarkers.
Other relationships can be established to endpoints between a reference and target
population. And finally, a safety extrapolation plan,
including areas where safety extrapolation may not be sufficient, such
as age-specific toxicities.
So before I wrap up, I'm going to briefly use the initial approval of
selpercatinib as an example of some of these pediatric
extrapolation at MIDD considerations.
Selpercatinib is a small molecule RET inhibitor that was initially approved in
May 2020 for multiple indications.
Two of those approved indications included adolescent patients at the
time of initial approval, as shown here,
for both RET mutant medullary thyroid cancer and RET fusion
positive thyroid cancersThe
approval of adolescent patients at the time of the initial approval was
supported by a pediatric extrapolation approach that included the following
considerations.
First, a combination of clinical and non-clinical data supported
high confidence in similarity of disease, drug pharmacology, and
response to treatment for both of the thyroid cancer
indications.
In addition, adolescent patients were eligible for the first inhuman
dose escalation and expansion trial of selpercatinib.
While ultimately few adolescent patients enrolled, given the rarity of disease,
the eligibility did result in availability of PK safety and activity
data from relevant adolescent patients.
Next, modeling and simulation was leveraged using additional
PK and safety data from lower body weight adults across a range of
dosages to support a recommended body weight-based dosing
strategy that would accommodate the expected range of body weights in
adolescent patients.
And finally, non-clinical data identified a potential pediatric
specific safety concern for patients whose growth plates had not yet
closed.
This pediatric specific safety concern led to the issuance of a
pediatric safety PMR
to monitor growth and development in pediatric patients.
Ultimately, the totality of data available from the pediatric extrapolation
approach allowed FDA to approve selpercatinib in adolescent
patients with no time delay from the initial approval in adults.
Notably, additional data were later collected as part of the iterative
pediatric extrapolation plan,
which led to expansion to even younger patients, now as young as age two.
So now before our next speaker, just a few quick take home messages.
Pediatric extrapolation supports safe, efficient and ethical
pediatric oncology drug development.
Pediatric extrapolation plans can leverage tools, including
MIDD to bridge knowledge gaps and inform pediatric trial designs.
Developers should consider pediatric extrapolation plans early in drug
development and update those plans as data emerge.
And finally, FDA is open for engagement and advice on pediatric
extrapolation plans throughout drug development.
I'd like to acknowledge the many people who contribute to this work.
And now I will hand it off to our next speaker, Jiang Liu.
Good afternoon. So it's such a great pleasure to be
here.
I'm Jiang Liu, currently the Deputy Division Director of
Pharmacometrics or Quantitative Clinical Pharmacology.
So here I will discuss how model informed drug development or
MIDD can support drug extrapolation for pediatric
cancer patients.
So following Lauren's introduction to extrapolation for
pediatric cancer patients, I will focus on the methodological
aspects, particularly how MIDD supports pediatric
extrapolation through the following three key areas:
leveraging existing data and knowledge to bridge
evidence gaps
and inform trial design and optimizing
dose selection. I will also introduce some case
examples, followed by key takeaways.
So, as Lauren introduced, under SHE 11,
pediatric extrapolation means borrowing existing evidence,
most often evidence of drug effectiveness, but sometimes
safety, from a reference population, usually adults
or older children, to support drug effectiveness
and use in the pediatric population when there's
sufficient similarity in disease, drug pharmacology,
and response to treatment, such that we don't need to repeat the
full efficacy trials in the pediatric population to
improve efficiency.
To support
these three core similarities and in turn
extrapolation, mechanistic understanding and
quantitative modeling using relevant surrogates
such as drug exposure and pharmacodynamic
response to demonstrate sufficient
similarity after treatment between the pediatric and the
reference population are critical.
So these slides provide a high level overview of
MIDD as a tool to support drug development.
As a quantitative approach, MIDD covers a wide range
of modeling and simulation methods,
including pharmacokinetics and pharmacodynamics,
PK/PD, and population PK, and
physiologically based pharmacokinetics,
PBPK,
exposure response analysis, and quantitative systems
pharmacology or QSP and others. Because of
time
limitations, I will not introduce each of these in
details.
Broadly speaking,
MIDD involves the development and application of
exposure based biological and pharmacological
models derived from preclinical and clinical
data sources to improve the efficiency of drug
development, patient care, and regulatory decision.
So MIDD provide a framework
combining mechanistic understanding with quantitative
reasoning to support the extrapolationIt
enable us to leverage existing data and knowledge
to support the core similarity justification, such as
based on similar exposure response or mechanistic
modeling.
Also design more informative trials and select the right
dosage in the pediatric population.
Regarding trial design, for example, a strong
understanding of disease, drug pharmacology and response,
together with accumulated experience with
quantitative clinical pharmacology for oncology
products in adolescents and adult patients,
had lead to policies supporting the inclusion of
adolescents in adult oncology clinical
trials for earlier evaluation. So MIDD
approaches for evaluating drug exposure can
inform dose selection in adolescents, often based
on prior PK knowledges in adults, plus
scaling according to the body size in adolescents.
And because pediatric trials face significant ethical and
logistical challenges, modeling and simulation should be
conducted proactively to guide exposure
target, dose level, and formulation selection,
as well as to inform sample size and sampling schedules
to maximize trial success and minimize burden.
So FDA recommends using
MIDD to support pediatric dose selection
because we understand that children are not simply small
adults. Children have unique physiological and
metabolic difference from adults.
To select a pediatric dose that achieves
exposure similar to the one established in the reference
population, an iterative process using
MIDD via
integration, prediction, optimization, confirmation,
and refinement plays a critical role.
So MIDD tools integrate with mechanistic
understanding of drug pharmacology, physiological
difference, ontology, the development of biological
systems such as enzyme, organs,
receptor expression, and the immune system with age and
others,
can help identify the
appropriate exposure
target based on the best available information from
adults and drugs in the same class for PK
bridging, and can also help evaluate potential
risk to pediatric growth and development.
So here are some examples which MIDD has
directly supported pediatric extrapolation for cancer
patients. For gadolinium-based
contrast agency,
GBCA, mechanistic understanding of drug
pharmacology and response, supported by quantitative
reasoning, enabled drug use in neonates and
infants. And for RILACE, population PK and
PD modeling on enzyme activity supported
extrapolation and dosing regimens that were
not directly tested in clinical trials for pediatric
patients. And for biologics such as
itolizumab and rituximab, MIDD
supported extrapolation and dosing recommendations
in younger children, such as down to two years old
or down to six months old,
based on datas from adults and older children.
So using GBCAs as an example, we currently have
10 GBCAs approved, and most of them have
pediatric indications down to neonate.
And pediatric use, particularly in neonates and infants,
was based on extrapolation supported by the core
similarities in disease, drug pharmacology, and
response. So in terms of drug pharmacology,
GBCAs rapidly distribute into the
extracellular space and are predominantly cleared
by the kidney with a short PK half-life of one to
two hours. And in terms of response,
concentration shortly after administration, for example,
20 to 30 minutes, are very relevant for
imaging efficacy.
Because GBCAs are predominantly
eliminated by the kidney, so mechanistically
understanding of the physiological
difference in kidney between pediatric patients and
adults is important for pediatric extrapolation and
dose selection, particularly in neonates and
infants. So as shown in the plots on the left
side, absolute renal function measured by GFR
increased with patient growth based on data from eight
studies.
However, after adjusted for body size, as shown
in the plots on the right side,
renal function
matures approximately two years after birth.
Therefore, renal function and the GBCA clearance,
particularly in infants, can be quantitatively described
by a model integrating body weight and
postmenopausal age in a
child.Therefore,
extrapolation of GPCS to neonate and infants was
based on robust clinical experience in older
children and adults together with PK modeling that
it integrates our mechanistic understanding of kidney
maturation
and the effects of body size on drug
distribution and clearance. And the
figure on the right
illustrate an example that the recommended dose
supported by modeling is expected to provide early
exposure,
specifically concentrations 20 to 30 minutes after dosing
in neonates and infants that is comparable to
those in older children and adults, which support
extrapolation.
So to support the efficient drug development and the
extrapolation for pediatric cancer patients, as well as the
appropriate use of MIDD approaches,
developers are encouraged to discuss their
strategies early with the
agency using various mechanisms such as
pediatric study plan or pediatric study request
at milestone meetings, or through dedicated type
D meeting or MIDD-focused meeting
for more of those specific issues.
FDA guidance and the published documents provide the
transparency and
detailed expectations regarding ethical
considerations, extrapolation strategies, trial
design and conduct, and data interpretation and
modeling.
So to summarize, regulatory policies such as ICH
E11A supports borrowing existing evidence
from a reference population for drug use in pediatric
population when there's sufficient similarity in disease,
drug pharmacology, and response.
And MIDD approaches, which can integrate data from
various sources, can enhance our mechanistic
understanding and quantitative
reasoning to improve the efficiency of oncology
pediatric extrapolation through evidence bridging,
more informative trial design, and dose optimization.
And early and open dialogue with the FDA also
helps support more efficient development
and timely access
to safe and effective
treatment for pediatric cancer patients.
So with that, I'd like to acknowledge my colleagues from the FDA
and thank you all for your attention.
And now I will pass the floor to next speaker.
Thank you.
Good afternoon. My name is Nicole Dresner.
I am a pediatric oncologist and Deputy Director of the Division of Oncology
2 at the FDA.
I'll be speaking about a recent example of pediatric
extrapolation from my division,
in the 2024 approval of Lutathera for adolescents with somatostatin
receptor positive gastroenteropancreatic neuroendocrine
tumors, or GEP-NETs.
Our review and approval applied the principles of the
extrapolation framework that you heard about in the previous two presentations.
GEP-NETs are a clinically heterogeneous spectrum of tumors arising from
neuroendocrine cells in the GI tract, pancreas, bile duct, and
gallbladder, and express the somatostatin receptor in over 90% of
cases. In the US, approximately 200 adolescents are
diagnosed with GEP-NET per year.
Metastatic GEP-NET is characterized by an indolent disease course but with an
overall poor prognosis. And prior to 2024, there were
no approved therapies for pediatric patients, though off-label use
according to adult treatment paradigms is
common. As you heard, one of the major
considerations for the use of extrapolation is whether the adult and
pediatric disease are sufficiently similar to allow for comparison
and use of adult data. There are some notable differences
in GEP-NETs between adolescents and adults, namely that pediatric
GEP-NETs are predominantly Grades 1 or 2, with a fewer proportion
of Grade 3 patients compared to adults,
and a comparatively high proportion of pediatric GEP-NETs are
associated with hereditary cancer predisposition syndromes,
namely MEN 1, Von Hippel-Lindau, NF1, and Tuberous Sclerosis
Complex. However, importantly, for this application for an
SSTR targeting therapy, SSTR expression is a
clinically relevant biomarker across all age groups.
Although historical data in adolescents are limited due to the disease
rarity, a high prevalence of SSTR expression in Grades 1 to
2 GEP-NETs is described in registries and the
literature. Therefore, somatostatin analog and targeted
peptide receptor radionuclide therapies are a feasible approach to treatment in
adolescents.
Lutathera is a radiolabeled somatostatin analog that was initially
approved in 2018 for the treatment of adults with
SSTR-positive GEP-NETs based on the results of the NETTER-1
study. NETTER-1 was an international randomized controlled trial of
Lutathera plus long-acting octreotide versus long-acting
octreotide in 229 adults with well-differentiated
metastatic midgut tumors. The primary endpoint of
blinded independent centrally reviewed assessed progression-free survival, or
PFS, demonstrated a statistically significant improvement
with Lutathera treatment with a hazard ratio of 0.21.
Notably, the ORR, overall response rate, was 13% in the
Lutathera arm.Given that there were no approved therapies for
adolescent patients with GEP-NETs, the FDA issued a written request in
2020 for a pediatric study to provide evidence for the safe and
effective use of Lutathera in this population, and the NETTER-P
study was initiated in 2022.
NETTER-P is an international multicenter single-arm study
enrolling adolescents with SSTR-positive GEP-NETs or
pheochromocytoma paraganglioma, or PPGLs.
PPGLs are rare neuroendocrine tumors arising from the chromaffin
cells of the adrenal medulla or sympathetic or parasympathetic
ganglia that also express SSTR and were included to provide
safety and dosimetry data for Lutathera in a broader
population. The primary endpoints were target organ absorbed
radiation doses and adverse events in laboratory toxicities in the
pooled cohort of patients. Given the single-arm nature of the study
and low projected enrollment due to the disease rarity, efficacy was
evaluated as an exploratory endpoint.
Enrolled patients received the approved dose and schedule of Lutathera.
In total, safety was evaluated in nine patients enrolled on NETTER-P at the
time of approval, including four patients with GEP-NET.
The adverse event profile was similar to that observed in adults, with the most
common observed adverse events and Grade 3 or higher adverse events being
lymphopenia and neutropenia.
The US Prescribing Information, or USPI,
for Lutathera notes that the risk of radiation exposure associated with
Lutathera are greater in pediatric patients than in adult patients due to
their longer life expectancy, acknowledging the known long-term effects of
radiation and radiopharmaceuticals.
No clinically relevant difference in Lutathera exposure between NETTER-P
patients and adults was observed, and the estimated radiation
doses were largely similar between adults and
pediatric patients, with one exception that I will discuss next.
The study also reported a best response of stable disease across
the pooled cohort of patients, though this was considered consistent with the adult
experience, namely the ORR of 13% that was observed in the
Lutathera arm of NETTER-1. One patient with GEP-NET had
disease progression at 8.6 months.
Dosimetry refers to the determination and measurement of the amount or
dose of radiation absorbed by organs throughout the body.
As I mentioned, target organ dosimetry values were similar between adults and
adolescents who received Lutathera.
The dosimetry extrapolation model, which compared median dosimetry
values with 5th and 95th percentiles, showed that neither
kidney nor bone marrow estimates from adults with GEP-NET were affected by the
addition of the pooled adolescent data, confirming the similar dosimetry
estimates between the two groups.
However, as shown in the top red box in the table on this slide, the
observed probabilities of exceeding 29 gray for the kidneys and two
gray for the bone marrow after four cycles of Lutathera did not
exceed 20% in adolescents, which were the thresholds selected for the
trial. The 29 gray threshold was selected based on published
literature that noted no grade greater than three
nephrotoxicity in 11 patients with kidney absorbed doses
exceeding 28 gray after treatment with Lutathera.
However, as shown in the bottom red box, the 95th percentile of the
predicted probability of exceeding 29 gray for the kidneys in
adolescents was higher than 20%. The confidence interval
around the predicted probability is wide due to the small number of adolescent
patients, and so these findings should be interpreted with caution.
But late onset renal toxicity is a known risk of radiopharmaceuticals,
including Lutathera. We consider this potential increased risk in
adolescents in the context of the overall risk-benefit profile that was
supported by a large PFS benefit in
NETTER-1. Our key review questions focused
on whether it is appropriate to extrapolate data from adult patients with
GEP-NETs to adolescents and whether the safety and effectiveness of
Lutathera in a rare pediatric population with limited data could be
extrapolated from adults.
As a reminder, the pediatric extrapolation framework requires assessment of the
similarities and differences between the reference and target populations with
respect to the disease, investigational drug pharmacology in response to
treatment, an assessment of the available safety information, and an
assessment of the gaps in knowledge for the extrapolated population and
how this affects the confidence and uncertainties of the extrapolation concept.
The FDA review team determined that extrapolation of adult
data to adolescents with GEP-NETs was appropriate, and the totality of
data across the adult and adolescent populations provided
substantial evidence of safety and effectiveness of Lutathera for
adolescents. This was based on the similarity of the disease,
particularly in that the expected response to a targeted therapy was assumed to be
the same in patients with SSTR expression, and that the
exposure-response relationships for efficacy and safety were also
expected to be similar. Given the extreme rarity of GEP-NETs in
adolescent patients, a randomized controlled trial was considered infeasible,
and since time to event endpoints are
uninterpretable in single-arm trials, our assessment of efficacy
was heavily extrapolated from the adult experience, including NETTER-1
and supportive data from an expanded access study conducted in the Netherlands.
The FDA review highlighted the similarities in safety, pharmacokinetics, and
dosimetry assessments between the two groups.
The large, clinically meaningful, and statistically robust PFS effect in adult
patients treated with Lutathera on NETTER-1 provided strong
evidence for the treatment's effectiveness and supported its extrapolation to a
rare pediatric population with a high unmet need and no FDA-approved
therapies.
Given the relatively short safety follow-up for the NETTER-P study at the time of
application submission, post-marketing requirements, or PMRs, for
an evaluation of the two major long-term toxicities, renal
failure and myelodysplastic syndrome and acute leukemias, were
issued for the conduct of safety analyses after five and 10 years of
follow-up. This data will augment our understanding of the safety
profile of Lutathera in adolescent patients and provide necessary
information on whether additional dose modifications or monitoring
recommendations are warranted.The robust
effect on PFS observed in the NETTER-1 trial provided a strong
basis for considering extrapolation in this
case. And the NETTER-P trial was able to provide important safety,
dosimetry, and clinical pharmacology data in a small number of pediatric
patients. Post-marketing requirements were issued for long-term
safety follow-up. In summary, the approval of Lutathera for adolescents with
GEPNETS is an example of the successful extrapolation of adult data to
support a new indication in a rare pediatric disease.
And I would like to thank the panel and the entire team at the FDA. Thanks.
Hi, good afternoon.
And
thank you for the opportunity to speak here today.
My name is Mansi Dalal. I'm a pediatric oncologist and a clinical reviewer
in the Division of Hemomalignancies 1 at the FDA.
And I will be giving our last presentation today, so stick with it.
And I'll be discussing a case study to demonstrate the scientific and
regulatory aspects of how pediatric
extrapolation was leveraged in the clinical development program for blinatumomab.
So B-cell acute lymphoblastic leukemia or B-ALL,
is the most common pediatric cancer and the second most common acute
leukemia in adults, which if left untreated, is universally
fatal.
B-ALL originates in the bone marrow from the malignant transformation of
progenitor B-cell lymphoid cells
and can infiltrate the extra medullary spaces, including the peripheral blood,
lymph nodes, the central nervous system, and the testicles.
B-ALL is also characterized by uniform cell surface
expression of CD19 in newly diagnosed
patients and patients with relapse post-chemotherapy.
The outcome of pediatric patients with B-ALL incrementally
improved through the optimization of risk-stratified and risk-adapted
treatment regimen, sequential combinations of multiphasic
cytotoxic chemotherapy, and central nervous system prophylaxis.
However, relapse, and long-term and late
toxicities of cytotoxic therapies continue to remain a major
challenge.
The current treatment paradigm of ALL in both adults and
children entail three phases: induction,
consolidation, and maintenance.
While the specific combination of therapies used may be different, the
goals of each phase are similar in adults and pediatric patients.
In general, the goal of induction phase is to achieve complete remission,
and the goal of consolidation and maintenance phases is to maintain
remission and improve overall survival.
Blinatumomab is a bispecific CD19-directed CD3
T-cell engager. It forms a synapse between CD3 T cells
and CD19 positive target cells, leading to
upregulation of cell adhesion molecules and production
of cytolytic proteins, release of inflammatory cytokines,
leading to redirected lysis of CD19 positive target
cells, including B-cell ALL blasts.
Currently, blinatumomab is dose-fixed or BSA-based and given as a
28-day continuous intravenous infusion followed by
two weeks of treatment-free period.
The exact dosing, including the use of step dosing, depends on
the indication it is being used for.
Cytokine release syndrome and neurological toxicities,
including immune effector cell-associated neurotoxicity
syndrome or ICANS, are two serious safety risks
associated with blinatumomab, for which there is a box warning in the
US prescribing information or USPI.
Other adverse reactions include
infusion-related reactions, infections, tumor lysis syndrome,
neutropenia, febrile neutropenia, and elevated liver enzymes.
So let's discuss how pediatric extrapolation framework, which you heard from Lauren
earlier today, would be applied to blinatumomab.
The main components of the extrapolation concept are to determine the
similarities and differences in the disease, the drug pharmacology,
response to treatment, and safety between the adult and pediatric
population with CD19 positive B-cell ALL.
For CD19 positive B-cell ALL, a very high degree of
disease similarities between adult and pediatric population exists,
including the pathophysiology, the course of the disease, and the
diagnostic criteria used.
Furthermore, CD19 expression, which is very relevant to a
CD19-directed therapy such as blinatumomab, is similar
in both adult and pediatric populations and expressed
uniformly on the leukemic blasts in the newly diagnosed and
post-chemotherapy relapse disease states.
Next, the cellular level mechanism of blinatumomab is not
affected by age, growth, and hormonal status.
And in fact, T cell, B cell, CD3, and
CD19 are present and functional
from infancy to older age.
Finally, the anticipated exposure-response relationship
between the pediatric and adult patients was
postulated to be similar, meaning that
because of similarity in the disease and the mechanism of action,
achieving a similar drug exposure in pediatric patients
would lead to a similar clinical response when compared to
adults.
This slide provides an overview of the blinatumomab approvals.
Pediatric extrapolation was utilized throughout the entire clinical
development program for blinatumomab.Blinatumomab was
initially approved in 2014 under the Accelerated Approval Pathway for
patients with relapsed/refractory Philadelphia chromosome-negative
ALL weighing at least 45 kilograms based on the endpoint of complete
remission and complete remission with incomplete hematologic recovery
with durability.
This initial study established the efficacy and safety of blinatumomab
in
monotherapy in the source population, the adult patients, in the
relapsed/refractory setting.
At the time of this approval, a dedicated pediatric study,
MT103205, was underway, which was a
dose-finding and dose expansion study to evaluate BSA-based
dosing, safety, tolerability, and antitumor activity in
children less than 18 years of age with relapsed/refractory
B-cell ALL.
The study demonstrated that blinatumomab was well-tolerated, with
lower incidences of neurological toxicities and similar
cytokine release syndrome rates in children compared to the adults.
Thus, BSA-based dosing of blinatumomab was approved for patients
who were weighing under 45 kilos with
relapsed/refractory Philadelphia chromosome-negative ALL, and the
primary efficacy results
from the study 205 was also included in the US prescribing
information in 2016.
Next, in 2018, blinatumomab was approved for treatment of ALL
in the first or second remission with minimal residual disease under the
Accelerated Approval Pathway. The basis of approval was the
BLAST study,
which was a single-arm study of adults greater than or equal to 18 years.
Eighty-one percent of patients achieved MRD negativity after one cycle
of blinatumomab. Note that there were no pediatric patients
enrolled on the BLAST study. Efficacy to the pediatric patients
was extrapolated from this adequate and well-controlled study
in adults with MRD positive B-cell ALL.
And safety was known from a adequate and well-controlled study in
pediatric patients with relapsed/refractory B-cell ALL, the study
205, as I discussed earlier. Thus, the conclusion was to grant an
age-agnostic indication for MRD positive B-cell ALL.
Finally, in 2014, blinatumomab was approved for the
treatment of Philadelphia chromosome negative B-cell ALL in consolidation
phase with multi-phase chemotherapy in adults and children.
Let's discuss how extrapolation was utilized in this setting in more
detail.
The basis of approval for consolidation indication of blinatumomab in the
context of multi-phase chemotherapy was based on three randomized
control trials
and a supportive meta-analysis that was conducted by the FDA.
In all studies, patient received blinatumomab after induction phase
with chemotherapy
that they received afterwards.
Study E1910 was a randomized study to compare overall
survival between blinatumomab and chemotherapy versus chemotherapy
alone in both MRD positive and MRD
negative disease states in adults 30 to 70 years of age
with Philadelphia chromosome negative B-cell ALL.
The MRD arm showed that intercalating blinatumomab and
chemotherapy led to a survival benefit and established
efficacy and safety of blinatumomab in the consolidation phase within
the context of multi-phase chemotherapy in adults.
The study 201/20215 was also a
randomized study of patients 28 days old to 18
years with first relapse of Philadelphia chromosome negative B-cell
ALL. FDA performed a descriptive analysis of overall
survival, or OS, and post hoc analysis of relapse-free
survival, or RFS, which showed a survival benefit.
And finally, study AALL 1331 was a
cooperative group randomized study of chemotherapy and blinatumomab
versus chemotherapy alone and enrolled patients with low risk or high
risk B-cell ALL after first relapse.
This study showed a trend towards a survival benefit in a descriptive
analysis.
All OS hazard ratio point estimates in the comparison
across the three trials favored the blinatumomab
containing arm. But only one comparison, MRD negative treatment
group in study E1910, met the pre-specified
criteria for statistical significance.
So a question arose of whether the positive result of
E1910, which was a study enrolling only adult patients,
and the supportive information of survival benefit from the two pediatric
studies, was adequate to extrapolate efficacy to pediatric
patients in the newly diagnosed consolidation phase setting.
To answer this question, the FDA performed a study-level
meta-analysis. In addition to the three randomized studies that I just
discussed, a additional published study called
BLIM-FANT, which was a single-arm study that included infants
with newly diagnosed Philadelphia chromosome negative KMT2A
rearranged B-cell ALL, who received one cycle of blinatumomab
in consolidation followed by chemotherapy with a reported
positive exploratory survival benefit when compared to a historical
control.
So a total of six study-level comparisons across four
trials were performed in this meta-analysis.
The comparison showed that the Philadelphia negative B-cell ALL
blinatumomab intercalated with the chemotherapy
backbone in the consolidation phase had a survival benefit
and a consistent treatment effect was seen across age and
lines of therapy, regardless of the chemotherapy backbone used.
It was already known that Philadelphia chromosome negative B-cell ALL
is a similar disease with
similar treatment paradigm
with respect to multi-phase... chemotherapy in adults and children.
Safety of blinatumomab was known in children as young as one month old from
prior clinical studies. And PK analysis from the pediatric
studies in this application who received blinatumomab in the
consolidation phase showed a similar steady state
exposure when compared to the children with relapsed refractory
ALL in the prior studies.
Based on all of the combined information, the consolidation approval
was extended to the first-line treatment for children with
blinatumomab and chemotherapy from the adult patients.
Thus, efficacy extrapolation occurred across age group and line of therapy,
regardless of the chemotherapy backbone used.
The indication statement in the USPI is shown at the bottom of the
slide.
So in conclusion, the framework for extrapolation based on similarity of
disease, drug pharmacology, and response to treatment between adults and
children led to an efficient pediatric drug development
for blinatumomab. Majority of the extrapolation was
supported by safety and dosing data from blinatumomab monotherapy
studies in children and adults. It should be noted that the degree of
extrapolation was enabled due to the robust and comprehensive
drug development program.
And in fact, so the data package did support
extrapolation to pediatric patients from adults in newly diagnosed
setting in consolidation phase to pediatric patients.
And just a few weeks after this consolidation approval,
the study AALL 1731, which was
a study being done by Children's Oncology Group of
pediatric patients receiving blinatumomab plus
chemotherapy versus chemotherapy alone,
underwent a planned interim analysis
for the primary endpoint,
which showed a significant improvement in three-year disease-free
survival in the blinatumomab and chemotherapy arm.
With that, I would like to thank the following colleagues and the wonderful panel
members on their collaboration for this presentation today. Thank you.
I will hand it over to Dr. Martha.
Thank you so much, Nancy, and all the other FDA presenters.
Vicki and Adam, I know that I introduced you earlier on today, but if you
want to provide a little bit more information about your background before we dive
in.
Thank you, Martha.
I really appreciate AACR and FDA's commitment to this topic.
So I'm Vicki Binger. I'm a retired academic and a bereaved
parent, and I've spent the past many years
working at the intersection of pediatric oncology research and
policy, specifically focusing on agent
prioritization and clinical trial
efficacy. And so this is right up my alley, and
I'm happy to be here.
Hi, I'm Adam Levy. I'm a pediatric hematologist oncologist.
I was in academia until four years and a month ago.
And I was
lucky to
join the team at Bristol Myers Squibb, where I lead the Pediatric Center of
Excellence and really charged with making sure
that the company focuses on pediatric drug
development and utilizing its pipeline as best as we could. Thanks.
Thanks, Vicki and Adam. I'm going to start off with a question for both of you.
Whoever wants to start first can. So as described by the presentations of
my colleagues, given the rarity of pediatric cancers, we have been
using extrapolation, including the use of model-informed drug development,
as an important tool at our disposal to leverage data accumulated in
adults to help inform our understanding of the safety and effectiveness of
drugs in oncology to treat pediatric patients, and the circumstances in which
we can assume that the diseases are sufficiently
similar and likely to respond to treatment similarly.
However, the way I see it, there's a certain degree of uncertainty
that can be introduced when we're using the adult data to support a
smaller data set than we typically would see in pediatric
patients for drug development and approval decisions.
So Vicki, well, maybe I'll start with you first because I know you're fast on your
feet.
Can you give us a little bit of insight as to your views, hearing all this, on the
way we're using extrapolation and in particular, your
perspectives regarding the factors that we should be
considering influencing the amount of uncertainty that
patients and their families are willing to undertake
when we're making decisions?
Sure. Well, on the whole, I'm a fan,
especially since ICH E11A.
I think that opens up the possibility of breaking down
that access delay that we talk about, I think in almost every pediatric
oncology session about how long it takes between adults having
access to therapeutics and children having access.
And it actually fits into my thinking that in
clinical trials, at least in pediatrics, our patients are
our most precious and scarce resource.
So if there are good, reasonable, safe ways of
sparing them from clinical trial participation, that's a good
thing,
because I think ultimately it's unethical
to expose children to any more trials than is strictly
necessary. I will say,
Martha, that for patients and caregivers, the concept that we saw in
several of the slides of sufficiently similar and
sufficient prospect of direct benefit,
and that emphasis on sufficient in both cases is doing a lot of
heavy liftingAnd so I think I really
appreciated having the different examples to show that there
are some times where the biology and
so forth are very close, but maybe you have to go ahead and
use children to figure out the safety pieces
or the dosing pieces. So
when you start thinking about the uncertainty, it's really
crucial for patients, caregivers,
parents, them, us, to understand
the way the FDA is approaching the extrapolation based on the way you
explained it
today. That it's over a spectrum, that it's a
continuum, that
the use of it can change over time, because this makes it
less like an all or nothing thing and sort of
deescalates some of the scariest parts and some of the biggest
uncertainties. So I think the main thing that patients and families will
think about is the differences between children and adults.
But what extrapolation means when you think about
its application, what you have to think about is what data from
adults is available and if that data is
applicable. So we've discussed today the situations
where adults and children share the same target, and in that
case, there's a lot of certainty about the biology.
But
I think that our biggest uncertainties are around the dosing or
safety where there might be
relying solely on adult data
is not perfect, and if that means that we can bridge the gap with fewer
pediatric patients, that's still sort of a win.
That being said, I don't think that most patient advocates or parents
know very much about this at all.
I don't think it's
a point of discussion in the kitchen on the
hospital floor late at night. It's not at our cocktail parties.
I would be surprised if it were.
I just don't think it's widely recognized or discussed.
And so listen, parents
need to know what they're consenting to,
and I think that they would be comforted by the
flexibility and the standards that we've heard about today, and
so they probably would think of extrapolation
as beneficial. But it is actually
always the case with informed consent in children with
cancer that we are both simultaneously optimistic
and cautious,
and this would apply to extrapolation because you really never know about the
long-term effects or the long-term safety.
And so that's where the uncertainty from a patient perspective is.
Thanks, Vicki. And I think that is sort of, I think you saw it in
at least maybe one of the examples
that's where we... Or maybe two, where we
use post-marketing requirements to follow patients in a more systematic way to
reassure ourselves that we're understanding the risk part of it and how best
to mitigate it. But thank you. And I guess in the future, it'd be great
to hear your thoughts either here or later regarding whether you
think we should be communicating this a little bit more effectively to parents and
how. How would be the big question, really.
Turning to you next, Adam.
Given that you've been now in industry for, was it four years and a month?
Did I get it?
Can you give us a little bit of insight
from your experience, and I don't know if you had a chance to talk to any of your
colleagues about this.
How do your industry colleagues feel about using extrapolation?
Is it something that they think of or tend to think of early on in the
adult development program when there may be pediatric applicability?
Just can you give us a... And if not, why do you think not?
Sure. Thanks so much for that question.
I think it depends who you ask within industry.
So there are a lot of industry pediatric-focused colleagues in the room here, and I
think those folks are probably very, very comfortable about
extrapolation. And in fact, I think the templates for a lot of
their health authority regulatory documents include templated language
about what's your extrapolation plan.
So even folks that don't focus on pediatrics are triggered to think
about it.
So I think the awareness is there. I think for colleagues who
don't necessarily focus on pediatrics all the time, the real issue is that
it's a theoretical thing, and they don't have necessary
experience with success in seeking extrapolation as part of the
development plan, and they don't have an awareness of,
well, how far can we go with extrapolation?
So
some of the language, as Vicki mentioned is,
what's sufficiently similar mean?
And that is a real hang-up for folks who were not in this
domain all the time.
So part of the thing I spend my time at the company,
and I'd love to hear from other colleagues in industry at the Q&A,
is really trying to educate development teams
about this very issue, about inclusion of adolescents in adult
trials so that we can really push this envelope and that we can enhance the
comfort in doing it.
So to your second part of your question, so if it's not widely used,
why not? So that's one of the reasons why not.
It's just kind of an awareness of how that would look.
And the other thing is, in my experience, and I'm not talking about my company
specifically now, I'm talking more broadly, there is great
hesitation about uncertainty.
And
I'm still evolving to understand the depth of that
concern about uncertainty.
In your presentations, it's wonderful about talking about having early meetings
with health authorities, and that is
greatFrom an industry perspective, we have to
appreciate what does that look like.
And what that looks like is massive size teams getting
together to make sure that the presentation is
appropriate and that
there's nothing in jeopardy by going to these discussions.
And
it's a different perspective from the company side
sometimes than it is
from when I was in academia or hearing from the other perspective.
So to summarize, I think it's, yes, there's awareness, but there's not enough
experience with success, and there's not enough certainty of what will
be acceptable, and all of those things
are inhibiting more
folks coming forward with extrapolation from the industry side.
Thanks, Adam. Can you elaborate a little bit more when you say that there might be
a concern about putting something in jeopardy when you have a conversation with FDA
about extrapolation? Is there-
Yeah
... something concrete that people might be afraid of when they
bring it up? Or is it just more a matter of the work it takes to put
together a meeting package and-
Yeah. I think there have been publications saying that this is a theoretical
concern that's not borne out.
Uh-huh.
So I want to really emphasize that.
And again, this is not specific to my company, and I'm talking as an
individual citizen-
Yeah
... not as a representative of the company.
But I think in general,
the regulatory
teams at companies feel that any interaction with
health authorities is an opportunity to get alignment, but it's
also an opportunity to be told that you have to do
something.
And that is an inherent risk from a company perspective.
That's a much longer conversation, but that's what I mean about jeopardy.
Okay.
Thank you.
Point's well taken.
Now I have a question for both of you, Vicki and Adam, before I start picking on my
FDA colleagues.
As described by Lauren, there's a continuum in the degree to which we can use
extrapolation. I think, Vicki, you alluded to that as well in your response.
In thinking about the examples that we gave here with
blinatumomab, Lutathera,
selpercatinib, and the gadolinium-based contract agents,
do you feel that we are sort of hitting the sweet spot in
terms of how we're gauging how heavily to lean on extrapolation for
the most part? Or
do you have any overall thoughts on that?
And if not, just what do you think, I
guess?
Right. Well,
I think that these were really helpful examples, and
so I do think that these versions did hit a sweet
spot by working through extrapolation
and showing how it can work and
how it can, in fact, lower patient
counts and encourage more concurrent approvals and speed things up.
I think that that's a nice thing. However,
I would say that if there is a
clear explanation to parents, and again, it's not
just about do they know it exists, but do they know what
it is, parents might not feel that sweet spot.
They might be concerned, and they might misinterpret
that children are being thought of as small
adults
rather than humans that are developing, rather
than having already developed bodies.
And this will fan fears of the unknown, I
think. And so if they hear about it and they don't get
further clear information about the continuum and the
care that's being taken. And so I would
say that
in that communication, the discussion about even more
emphasis on post-market surveillance might
be warranted, and really not just for a set amount
of time that would be a standard amount of time that you'd do
post-market, but the time that it would actually take a child to
develop to the point that they are out of the
woods for the kind of effects that might have been
missed in making the extrapolation.
And so, yeah, I think you're doing a really good job in the sweet spot, but I
think that the two concerns I would have are
parents understanding what you're doing
and then you understanding you need to explain it and
keep watching.
Thanks, Vicki.
Adam, what are your perspectives?
Yeah, thanks.
As a practicing pediatric oncologist, and I
think some of us on the panel have talked about this before,
we're extremely comfortable
using off-label drugs.
And by extremely, I mean we do it every day, probably for every
patient.
So again, if you're asking Adam, I would say
we should be more bullish about extrapolation in general, because
I have cognitive dissonance understanding how the standard of care is so
distinct from the
formal indications for drugs.
And I think
more robust extrapolation could close that gap.
So
yeah, I guess I'll leave it at that on
that question. I just wanted to
challenge something a little bit.
I know that we always say, and I in general agree, that children are not
little adults. But I also think that we have to be very careful with
pushing that narrative when we're trying to include adolescents in adult
trials. We have to kind of decide what do we mean by that
if we're going to say children are not little adults, because if that's the case,
thenWhat's
the theory behind including adolescents in adult trials?
And perhaps we should amend that old adage to say, except
adolescents, which are kind of little adults.
And maybe we should have that conversation more because,
again, when you ask from a company perspective what makes people
afraid,
well, we spent a decade or two saying that children are not little
adults, and then I go to a colleague and say, "Just include the 16-year-olds.
They're not any different than an 18-year-old." And then they say, "Well, children
are not little adults, and they're a child." So
now they don't know what to think. And we have to kind of own
that-
Confusion that we're sowing, yeah
... that we are sowing completely.
Yeah.
Because it doesn't really make sense, actually.
Yeah. Although I would say, and this is semantics, that at least my personal
view is that the pediatric spectrum
includes children, which I generally consider less than 12
years-ish of age. It's still a little arbitrary.
And then adolescents are part of pediatrics, but they're not children.
I understand that you believe that.
But it's confusing.
But
when you ask me what's a barrier within industry, I can tell you that-
Yeah, there's miscommunication
... that is a marketing thing that-
Yeah
... we need to do better in drawing that distinction.
Yeah.
In my opinion.
The point's well taken. We're going to have to start working on that messaging.
Thank you.
Nicole,
we have a lot of food for thought here, but I was curious about
whether you've seen any, particularly beside the Lutathera
example that you spoke of, have you seen
any other particularly unique or complicated cases where we've used
extrapolation to support approval, and how did
you work through that?
Yes. There are many, I think, many cases, and the degree to which we rely
on extrapolation differs. But I mentioned in the last
session, for anybody who was here, we approved
vorasidenib for adolescent and adult patients with
IDH-mutant low-grade glioma
on the basis of a randomized controlled trial.
It was international.
And although the trial was open to adolescents, it actually only enrolled
one adolescent patient to the placebo arm.
So we had no experience within that trial itself of an adolescent receiving the
drug for the specific indication.
Nevertheless,
we received the data package and the proposal to
write an indication statement that included adolescent patients, and I think we
really struggled with that
decision. Understanding that the company had made efforts
to engage
pediatric children's hospitals to open the study and were generally turned
down because of the rarity. Most
large centers probably only see one adolescent patient with IDH mutant
Grade 2 glioma
every few years. And so the prospect of opening an entire trial for that one
patient is difficult.
And so we did a lot of reading and relied
on the information that the sponsor provided to make a
determination on the similarity between IDH mutant low-grade
glioma as an adolescent
and whether it was sufficiently similar to adults, and ultimately determined that
it was,
understanding that there may be some difference, but the targeted
mechanism of the drug and the target really helped bridge
that gap. And in addition, I think like Vicki, you
said, it is a continuum, and the efficacy results really
did help in both the Lutathera example and the
vorasidenib example. The primary outcome measure
for the Indigo trial of vorasidenib was progression-free survival, also with a
hazard ratio of about 0.39,
and a secondary endpoint of time to next treatment with a hazard ratio of 0.26.
So in the face of such profound
improvement with the drug,
it really
sort of behooved us to make the argument to provide that
treatment also for adolescent patients, knowing that the prospect of having a
randomized controlled trial in adolescent patients with such a rare
disease would be almost nil. And then, so they would be left out
or left to off-label use.
Yeah. Thanks.
And did we put any
parameters around it? Is there anything that we did to help mitigate our
uncertainties?
Yes. So we issued post-marketing requirements as well for safety.
We did look throughout the expanded access program for both
vorasidenib and another IDH inhibitor.
So we did have some information, just not within
the original trial. But
we did request
post-marketing experience and including a summary of efficacy in
patients,
adolescents that are in the future enrolled in
expanded access or in other trials of vorasidenib
to provide that as a response to a post-marketing requirement
to follow up on safety and efficacy.
Thanks. I'm going to turn to Jiang and Lauren in a minute, but I see we have a
gentleman here at the podium. Thanks for waiting.
Thank you. Great talks. I have a question for the Clinical Pharmacology
Office. So for drugs like when the adult ER
relationship
evidence like for efficacy is flat or plateau while it's
positive for safety, so how would you define the target
exposure for pediatrics? How would you weigh in between matching the
exposure of adult versus more safety consideration
in pediatric? Thank you.
Oh, sorry.
Sure. So
I'm sure hopefully many of you are aware that Project Optimus
is FDA's initiative around dosage optimization
for oncology products, and it's something that now I think we're
at five years of really putting the
communication and effort into
promoting... alternatives to just looking at
MTD and escalating to MTD and the thinking that
more is better. And so in general, not just in pediatrics
but also in adults,
we are looking very closely and encouraging
sponsors to really think about the benefit-risk of any
selected dosage that they choose.
And so when there are really high-quality evidence from adults
that
we've saturated the efficacy, and we're in a sort of flat
part of an efficacy relationship,
then you can,
within that portion, really look at what the shape
of those safety relationships look like
and think about weighing the benefits and risks, and not
overexposing patients and giving them additional
toxicity when there's no additional prospective benefit.
And when we think about taking that into the sort of pediatric
extrapolation concept, we are thinking about,
do we need to match the exposures in pediatric patients?
Are there certain scenarios where an exposure differential in
pediatric patients may be either expected or actually be
desired? If there are differences between the pediatric disease
and the adult disease, sometimes there are scenarios where higher
exposure may be warranted in a pediatric
population. So we are thinking about those, and
when we meet with sponsors, and we talk about where things are going with the
development program,
we definitely are having those discussions around what is the rationale
for this dosage in general, in pediatrics specifically, is there a
scientific rationale for targeting the same exposure, targeting a different
exposure? And what is the benefit and
risk of that particular dosage? So I don't know if you want to add anything.
Yeah, I don't have much to add. Actually, if you are talking about
extrapolation, basically, we want to see a comparable
exposure compared to adult.
This also depend on the uncertainty we talked about a
lot here. But if your year relationship for
efficacy and safety is very reliable in adult,
then maybe we need additional efficacy
data because you have maybe pediatric will be known to be a little
more concerned, especially may identify the potential risk
for growth or development. Then maybe you can
generate additional efficacy data,
may come from external
data sources or other things to support maybe lower exposure
in
adult, which can provide
a favorable benefit risk in younger children.
But if you want to target a lower exposure, maybe need
additional data to support that because you have some
uncertainty there.
And these types of conversations are conversations that you're
really willing and want to have as early on as possible
with developers, right? Because each situation's a little
different, and you kind of have to customize a plan and think about the
metrics that you're looking for ahead of time, ideally. Right?
I guess I'll turn to you two quickly again.
Can you just provide in your experience, you both have a lot of experience at the
FDA,
reviewing applications and obviously have thought deeply about extrapolation and
development in peds.
Can you describe any challenges that you've encountered when considering use of
extrapolation or when you're reviewing applications alongside the
clinical teams and looking at the data?
Are there
typical challenges that you might encounter or things that you wish you could
address earlier on rather than later?
Do you want to start again or?
Okay, sure.
I can start first.
Okay.
Yeah.
Besides covering oncology area, I also covering
other therapeutic area. Actually, recently, we approved a
drug
for rare disease.
They didn't plan for this early enough, so
after submission, they want to get extrapolation down to
neonatal or infants. But
they actually had a lot of real-world data in
pediatrics, but they didn't collect any PK or
the safety information. They also didn't
collect high quality, those kind
of quantitative evidence to support their dose
selection. So in those individual
INDs, you can see the dose actually in pediatric
is
lower than they evaluated or established in
adult. So we face significant challenge and then
to
do extrapolation for those kind of situations.
So I guess the key
issue is if you want to make your extrapolation more
efficient, it's better you integrate those plans we
discussed as early as possible and negotiate,
have early engagement,
effective communication with the agency.
Also, this is iterative process or continuous
process.
Like I say, the use
modeling can help to integrate the different sources
of information then. But it's a iterative
process. You integrate, then you predict, then further you need
to optimize, confirm, and then refine.
That's a
lesson we learned. But early communication and open dialogue with
the agency is the key, I think.
Yeah. And I think both Martha and Jiang mentioned that
there are unique aspects to every single one of these development programs.
And so we learn something from every one of these that we have a
detailed discussion on.
And when there's not that upfront effort
and planning on what are the actual questions that we
need answered from this data, there can often become this
mismatch between what did we ultimately need and
what was perhaps gathered in a trial.
And so establishing those questions early can help in designing the
trial, not just how many pediatric patients do I need, but
also things like what PK sampling or pharmacodynamic
sampling is going to be most informative to answer and bridge those
gaps. And then the one other thing, I'm a pharmacist by training,
and so for anyone who was at the last session, there was a really great discussion
around age-appropriate formulation development.
That is very often a challenge for our oral
products. And so it's pretty frequent that we get
pediatric plans or studies where the science is at a point
where it makes sense to start evaluating this product in
children, but there's just not a way to actually get the drug
into children. And so the formulation development, there's a lot of effort that
goes into it that we know and we see, but it's definitely something that's
often a barrier.
Thanks, Lauren.
We only have a couple minutes left, and I want to thank you all for your attention.
If you have a question. You have a question?
This is for Dr. Dalal. Nice case study on blinatumomab.
I was just wondering, I know you highlighted the PK exposure matching and the
safety, given the assumptions. I'm just wondering, given the mechanism, how
much role PD played,
like PD data between adults and pediatrics in the decision making?
And maybe a more general question to both Lauren and Jiang
is,
given the criteria, again, for exposure matching,
any examples where you would actually need more than just the PK
exposure matching PD or any other evidence as examples?
That was a couple of questions.
Go for it.
Yeah. Thanks for that question.
So definitely pharmacodynamic data was
collected earlier on in the clinical development program for blinatumomab.
As I mentioned, there was a dedicated study in pediatric patients and adult
patients in monotherapy of blinatumomab in the relapse
refractory setting. So we had
known that CD19 positivity across the
age population was similar, but also that the leukemic blasts
themselves uniformly, at least in the newly diagnosed setting, also had
CD19 positivity. So I think
we sort of used that throughout the clinical
development program to state that.
All of the blinatumomab approvals are for
CD19 positive
acute lymphoblastic leukemia, because there are
rare patients who don't have CD19 positivity, and so they
would be a completely different disease and would not be able to get
CD19-directed therapy.
I don't know if that answers your question. Yeah.
The other thing to know, and I wasn't involved at all in the
review of this, so I can't give you any
specific information, but the applications that we review, and particularly when
we're using extrapolation, what's typical is that the clinical team
is reviewing the clinical data, and alongside the clinical team,
the Office of Clinical Pharmacology has clinical pharmacology
reviewers, pharmacometricians represented, like the colleagues of
Jiang and Lauren, looking at the
available PK data, looking at things like dose exposure-response
relationships, looking at the
exposure toxicity relationships.
And as we're going through the review, all of that
information is taken together in kind of putting together the whole thinking
about dosing for that particular patient population,
and whether we think it's appropriate to utilize, how and
when to use extrapolation. Is that fair to say?
Yeah.
I don't know if you want to add anything else to that.
I can maybe address a little of the sort of second part of the question as
well. A lot of the examples that we gave today
are examples where there was pretty high confidence in a very
high degree of similarity between the pediatric disease and the
adult disease. And so in those cases, thinking
about that continuum, there may be different types
or less evidence needed specifically in pediatric populations
where that exposure matching type approach may be more
appropriate. When we get into those scenarios where there's
more of a knowledge gap or less certainty in the similarity
between the reference data and where we're going with
pediatrics,
is where we need more data from those pediatric patients.
Sometimes that's PD data.
As a clinical pharmacologist, PK is always 100% of the time
involved. But as we move along that continuum
to sort of less similarity, more knowledge gaps, is often where
we are looking for additional types
of supportive data that may help us bridge those gaps.
Thanks, Lauren.
I don't see any questions, and we have one and a half minutes left.
So
maybe I'll just ask you guys if you have any key take home messages or
things we want people to take away as they leave here and go do, hopefully,
something fun.That would be great.
So Lauren, I don't know if you have anything else to add.
I know you just beautifully summarized something.
Yeah. I think we've encouraged a lot for sponsors to come and
discuss these plans upfront. I think that
it's always beneficial to have those plans
established upfront, to really be able to
leverage that data in the most effective way once we get that very,
very precious data from our pediatric patients.
Upfront, but maybe also iteratively as needed. Okay, go ahead.
Yeah. Actually, for me, I guess extrapolation always happened.
You extrapolate data evidence from
patients you tested in clinical trial to real-world
patients. And therefore, there's different degrees
of extrapolation. And the pediatric extrapolation
doesn't mean reduced evidence. It means
like reduced uncertainty,
using existing knowledge or datas,
therefore to support those similarities and to support the extrapolation.
So I don't think we are lowering our bars here.
And then to support this kind of efficient
extrapolation and early communication and mechanistic
understanding
will be important. Also,
main topic today is meaningful
efficacy extrapolation. As in safety extrapolation means
another thing that maybe need another discussion in the
future.
I'll just say from a clinical perspective, usually our decision
is coming in when we're trying to decide the
sufficiently similarity of the two diseases.
And so when we have our meetings, and
we know that there's a rare pediatric population, and we are trying
to make a determination of the similarity, it's helpful to have either
the opinions of, or even better, all of the sort of experts in the room with
us. So we do often ask and encourage industry
sponsors to bring their KOLs, so that we can
hear the perspectives of everyone at the same time.
And it does help when we're talking about rare diseases,
to have those additional perspectives.
Yeah. I'll just add to that from clinical perspective, I think,
as you have heard probably like a million times today,
I think early and frequent interaction between the sponsor and the FDA
is really helpful to develop clinical trials.
But not only just develop clinical trials for our pediatric patients, but to
generate the data that is needed to support the indication,
whether that's via extrapolation, so just generating the data to
support extrapolation, or
doing standard-alone studies. But oftentimes, I think we would
like to have more clinical trials that are
supporting the indication, and
having that frequent interaction would be helpful.
So speeding the time we spend in the valley of death,
using data as well as we can, and preserving our most
precious resource is not just possible, but thanks to the
FDA pushing forward on
this guidance,
it's actually happening. And the only final thing I would say
is don't forget that including patient advocates in whatever
planning and review you do as early as possible is also
advisable.
And you are definitely welcome at meetings too, as part of the KOLs.
Advocates are KOLs too, as well.
I'm just honored to have been a part of the panel.
So thanks for having industry representation and thanks for all the
lessons learned. I think from my perspective, take home is to really
embrace these great examples where extrapolation was a success,
and to really continue to champion from the industry and within industry,
to encourage folks to engage early and to use these as examples of
success for the future. So thanks so much.
Thank you, Adam. Thank you all, all of you for being here and for
participating in the panel, for the questions we got, and for all of your
attention, particularly late in the day.
This concludes today's sessions on the regulatory science and policy track.
Tomorrow at 12:30, please consider do come back because
we're going to close out the regulatory science and policy track at this year's
annual ACR meeting with a session led by one of my colleagues at the
FDA, Dr. Jeevan, I'm gonna mess his last name up,
Poothiaahmadopthal.
Okay. You can say it. You know how to say it, Nicole.
Thank you.
I call him Jeevan, so I never use his last name.
Anyways, he's going to give a great talk, and have a wonderful panel discussion on
use of artificial intelligence in oncology drug development.
And the title of the session is "The Code Meets Cure: Navigating the
Regulatory Landscape of AI in Oncology Drug Development." So hopefully we'll
see you there. And have a great night. Thank you all.